I should just all of the extract stimulates the immune system. I have Hashimoto, so I generally avoid immune system stimulates.
Why is person there currently taking all of the for sinus problems?
I write us as flared up any suggestions for a right us.
So yes, all of the extract is in direct immune stimulates. It's considered a direct immune stimulant.
So again, when you have white, so some people listening to this are like, what is this person talking about?
This person is wise, so they know they have Hashimoto. So Hashimoto's is antibodies to the thyroid plate.
So if you have self antibodies, we need antibodies to any self tissue, you have to be careful using herbal immune stimulates.
So, you know, vitamin C, garlic, echinacea, all of the extract, it falls into that category.
So that's a direct immune stimulant. Why do you have to be careful of that?
Because every time you stimulate your immune system, you will kill that which you have antibodies against first,
which means you're going to destroy, in this case, your thyroid is playing. So you have to be careful of that.
Now, can you use immune stimulants? What can I never use immune stimulants if I have, you know, an auto, have I have Hashimoto's?
No, I wouldn't say that. In a acute case, so like I got a really bad streptol, I need to take something.
You could take it for a few days. So use it wisely though, don't stay on it for a long period of time.
My right is this inflammation. What can you do about that? Well, you've got to find out why you have it.
Because if it's just irritation from some external source, is it an immune reaction because of an allergy?
You know, also, it's not uncommon to have antibodies to differ by tissue. So that's something you may want to look at to test it as well.
Remember, once you have antibodies to self-tissue like Hashimoto's, it's really easy for you to start developing antibodies to other self-tissue.
That's why you have to be careful to be letting your immune response.